[Musik]
deshalb wisse dass weder eine klappt
denn ja also quasi das ist eine klappert
dass sie zufährt so vor dem her ist das
nicht klappt hätte sich mich auch einen
umbringen
also das ist also das wieder gescheitert
michelle haus das leben aber noch mehr
hat sie sich selber
sie sehen sich nach geborgenheit acht
jahre lang begleitete ich mich ja wir
suchen eine heimat zu finden
[Musik]
michelle ist elf jahre alt als ich sie
zum ersten mal sehe ihre familie
begleitet sie im jahr 2005 in ein
kinderheim michelle der schnupperwoche
gemacht du kannst dir das geschlecht
jetzt froh den 2
doch der alltag im heim ist rauer
[Musik]
[Applaus]
michelles mutter die alleinerziehende
kam mit ihrer tochter nicht mehr zurecht
es ist immer eine unruhige see der
schlagerstar schwarzer sich immer
schwerer gewalt- und jetzt schaut
einfach wieder da jetzt einfach ruhe das
schloss kosten im aargau ist für mich
die erste station auf ihrer odyssee
durch viele kinderheime sie hat mühe mit
strukturen und regeln
und wenn schon immer mehr auseinander
das kann ist das leben schwer
[Musik]
es ist kurz vor weihnachten 2011 in
einer wohngemeinschaft im aargauischen
menziken treffe ich sie wieder
michael ist jetzt 17 und macht ein
hauswirtschafts praktikum sie 200 und
winchester es ist gut ich finde ich bin
zu jung für da also direkt mit abstand
aber ich wollte sowieso mit alten
liebschaft wenn ihr jetzt ein praktikum
da und es ich finds gut so richtig zu
hause war es in den letzten jahren
nirgends sie lebte ständig an einem
anderen ort waren rund 20 heimen die
wohngemeinschaft bietet menschen mit
unterschiedlichsten problemen einen
lebensraum zur bewohnerinnen tore hat
sie ein besonders enges verhältnis
[Musik]
einerseits macht die 17 jährige ein
praktikum
auf der anderen seite ist sie selber
patientin michel ist noch immer
psychisch instabil desinfektionsmittel
bh und und ich wasche meine hand ab doch
was nicht wieviel am tag bestellt muss
ich die stelle gut als infizieren kann
gestreckte bakterien und so sie erträgt
wenig distanz ein dilemma mit
absturzgefahr vor zwei wochen wollte sie
sich das leben nehmen
das problem gewesen oder zurückweisen
oder nicht akzeptiert werden dass ich
ins studio gehe und das musste ich immer
das gleiche und so dass ich dann im
wortlaut und den suizidversuch machen
und das ist steht den aussie ich bin
also ab gewisse wurde von beton und das
hat mich sehr verletzt
und wenn mich die person passen
charakterlich einmal mega glücklich und
eine plötzliche panik optimiert und kann
jetzt also wieder vergangenheit ist und
hier an ihre kindheit hat sie schlechte
erinnerungen
darüber reden möchte sie nicht auf ihre
geschiedenen eltern wollen nichts dazu
sagen
michel war sechs als ihren vater zum
letzten mal sah zur mutter hat sie ein
schwieriges verhältnis
[Musik]
im april 2012 befindet sich michel in
der psychiatrischen klinik königsfelden
im aargauischen windisch in der
wohngemeinschaft kam es zu einem
zwischenfall
daraufhin wollte sie sich erneut das
leben nehmen
ich stricke mit dem morgner von data und
dann bin ich voll ausgelastet und
sondern hat sich auch ein anderer
bewohner trick menschen und so kann ich
dir vorweg schöpfer doch dann haben sie
mich weiter produziert nicht verlust
gerade auf sie losgegangen
aber es ist nicht wieder passieren das
passiert mit ihr im nachhinein bist ja
bewusst was du da gemacht
weißt du gar nicht mehr was da mit dem
was ich gott ja doch wenn man es denn
schon bewusst und es tut mir leid
michelle befindet sich auf der
geschlossenen jugendstation hier könnte
sie auch den unterricht besuchen einen
schulabschluss hat sie nicht nur zimmer
mit cnet hat am unterricht ein
anstrengendes und es wird noch schneller
befördert
die chance
jürgen köppel ist chefarzt für kinder
und jugendpsychiatrie von ihm möchte ich
wissen was michel eigentlich genau hat
es folglich schon da und es gab im ganz
schwierige verhaute hörzu und da
befindet sie sich irgendwo auf dem
spektrum und ein teil von dem ist einer
der elf ihrer pubertät und ein teil
bereits für zukunft also genau die
persönlichkeitsstörung
wir sind sehr zurückhaltend die wir mit
dem auto von einer
persönlichkeitsstörung zu reden
wir sagen es besteht hinten zieht
richtig aber eigentlich die diagnose
normalerweise der schweiz erst im
wochenverlauf gesteckt in der küche mit
zu helfen ist das einzige wozu michel
momentan in der lage ist
und
irgendwie ist musiker noch nicht
automatisch presse therapeutin martina
obrist ist nicht als bezugsperson in der
klinik zurück in ihre alte
wohngemeinschaft darf sie nicht mehr
wieso ist jetzt wieder gut mit ihm ich
danke all das möglich aber schwierig für
dich zum wie so ein platz finden
ja schon aber weil ich schon fast das
ist probleme und die namen marie wurde
außerdem durch 7
warum dann ja weil ich ein beratungstag
locker bin also wird in wien nachfolger
hast du quasi ja so überrascht hat ist
jetzt drin der sache bestens
kontrollieren ja schon aus spitze aber
ich wäre ja die patienten die lehre
jetzt mit norden so noch im prinzip sehr
stark hat ein händler
ihre hand gebeten störe dass sie weniger
von den emotionen über land werden oder
übermannt werden und könnte gezielte
besser passen zum leben
mario ist der therapiehund after
jugendstation
mit gottes schöner hat über ein
hindernis
das machen die leute glücklich wenn ich
bin ich hier um mich an was macht ihn
glücklich weiß dass er auch herrlich hat
einfach ein allgemeiner herzig und wenn
man sich an streichen und so das
beruhigt einmal aus bitzen so
[Musik]
kostbar
so heißt michels und der seit november
2012 ihr begleiter ist
ganze sechs monate lang war michele in
der psychiatrie
wenige tage nach der entlassung treffe
ich die inzwischen 18-jährige wieder wie
gut ihr michael gut sehr gut
das ist die grundaussage klinikum sachen
machen was sie wollten die freiheit
freiheit designtes andere ich natürlich
war es wo man auch gedanken gemacht ich
hab mich einfach nur schaffen bis
reiniger wenig nach aber dann als
fachangestellte gesundheit richtigen der
plan wie das möchte ich natürlich ganz
zu und sie ja aber riecht es im moment
bin ich schon eher stabil als ist und
kann ich hoffe es wird einfach immer
besser
da sah ich mich stabil gibt es da ein
grund dass minister bis 81 kg äpfel mit
dem medikament tour in italien abgesetzt
und mit gott sagen ich gute niemand die
kommen jetzt ruft die kann man gar nicht
braucht haben uns mit so gut habe ich
mich von ihr gefühlt
michel scheint einen sinn im leben
gefunden zu haben
ich würde es ihm gönnen momentan wohnt
sie bei ihrer kollegin und bezieht
sozialhilfe
[Musik]
im mai 2013 besuche ich mich schnell bei
kollegin petra bei der sie unterschlupf
fand sie sieht anders aus und ihre
gemütslage hat sich verändert
die talente sind der psychiatrie kennen
du bist jetzt dreht sie der klinik
kritik sie was ist der grund warum das
in maxi und weil ich gebe dazu mal
eingreifen müssen handwerker im raum ist
herzzerreißend den augen aber grenzen
mexikos ist in ihren hund musste michael
weg geben weil sie nicht in der lage war
für ihn zu sorgen
beide frauen nehmen viele medikamente um
einigermaßen stabil zu bleiben
petrom michael haben ein ähnliches
schicksal und leiden unter demselben 2
[Musik]
dort wo gegen mich gerichtet ist nicht
derselbe rösler in dem das ich mal
schnyder in dem moment spüre ich mich
nicht und werde mich aber gespür und
dennis schmid ist für mich - van thiel
als ich lade die wort die luft oder im
rennen ist lang - und ich habe ich
wieder zu mir wenn über kriegs blogs
laufen dann weiß ich einfach angst vor
allem vom 7
für spieler jeden tag wenig fühlt zum
anderen zeigt dass minimale gefühl sind
[Musik]
im juli 2013 lerne ich miriam hartmann
kennen sie ist michaels beiständin
miriam hartmann hat für ihre klientin
einen platz in einer sozialen
einrichtung gefunden
stimmungsschwankungen prägten das
zusammenleben der beiden
es war eine schwierige zeit für alles
und wir müssen sehr viel bin ja nicht
aus der welt
schießen real ja
ich bin froh so fragt sie
man kann machen was ich will ist ein
[Musik]
blödsinn ich sehe ich auch zwingen
ich vermute dass michelle einfach mehr
hat mit strukturen mit regen und das
überall richtig die kontrolle ob sie mit
dem druck wenn es nicht um so dass man
sie am schluss den einfach mit
psychiatrie blockiert also ist es auch
der typ ist leistung ja so wenn sie
keine kletterten steckt
und da wünsche ich mir von gesellschaft
das macht stern ist halt einfach mit
natürlich sagen wie wir uns das
vorstellen
michelles neues zuhause
das gärtnerhaus im arabischen
meisterschwanden bietet menschen mit
psychischen problemen geschützte
arbeitsplätze an
ist das jetzt alles neu delhis 19 und
muss im gärtnerhaus lernen zu arbeiten
das ist etwas neues für sie
das ist die nächste niedrig
wir haben ja schön privat sie persönlich
schätze
er ist gott
wichtig für länder in die pflicht wenn
man dann auch für unsere ganze sache
[Musik]
im herbst 2013 befindet sich mich noch
immer im gärtnerhaus so lange war sie
noch selten am selben ort für sie ein
erfolg
eigentlich ist ganz anders
in diesem sind ganz nah dran
scheidenpilz vorstandschef liebe
hoffnung ist ein guter anfang
ich wünsche michael dass sie vertrauen
ins leben fast und ein ziel findet
momentan gelingt es hier täglich zwei
stunden zu arbeiten
kleine schritte für ein großes ziel
[Musik]